what happens if interest rates go up
though buy-to-let property investing is
so risky
I mean interest rates right now is so
low but if they just go up a little bit
it's gonna scope of most landlords how
scary how risky if you bird that said
then this video is for you so stay tuned
[Music]
so let me just say a couple things about
interest rates number one is yes
interest rates they are very very low
right now they have gone up a tiny
little bit in the last six months and
they probably will go up but listen this
is the important thing right now you can
fix your interest rates for up to 10
years now if they were going to shoot up
massively in the next few years
why on earth would lenders let you fix
interest rates for 10 years if you fix
it for 10 years you'd have to buy ten
percent I'm talking four five at max
I've just had one of my students who's
fixed their interest rate get this at
1.9% buy to let for five years if you
fix your interest rates they can't go up
certainly for 5-10 years secondly is
this the only thing that's going up
super fast anytime soon is house prices
and rents with the new section 24 rents
are shooting up even though you can
protect yourself while buying a limited
company with brexit people were scared
that house prices we're going to fall
but it hasn't happened I live in the
Midlands brexit was announced two years
ago and in the Midlands property prices
have gone up in some areas as much as 36
percent people say all brexit has
affected the prices in London because
since brexit was announced London prices
have dipped the only reason London
prices of depth is because there was a
massive expansion because from 2011 to
2016
five years parts of London doubled in
value and after a massive expansion like
that of course is going to be a little
foolish
it's got nothing to do with brexit so if
you're one of those people concerned
about interest rates going up just fix
them for crying out loud make sure that
there's plenty of cushion so if your
interest payments are three hundred
pounds a month and your rent is
400 pounds a month that's just 100
pounds teenie wanted to pound profit so
if there's a problem boiler breaks
interest rates go up a little bit you
know feel it more but if you've got 500
pounds 1,000 pounds per month in profit
every single month and interest rates go
up a little bit even if they double
you're still going to be in good profit
so here's let me tell you this there's
two types of people one always come up
with reasons why something cannot be
done and those people are always broke
the second kind of person is people that
come up with reasons was something can
be done and create solutions like fixing
their rates like having cushion in their
profit like buying through a company and
those are the rich people I'd love to
know your thoughts below
put down your comments what's going to
happen with interest rates what is going
to have me brexit comment below
subscribe for more god bless you thank
you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time